bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous ce
matin alors d'abord cette question
manière globale quel bilan vous faites
des arrestations au sens du mouvement
irak
bonjour madame je pense qu'aujourd'hui
la gérer a vraiment est vraiment passés
par une phase d'un petit peu difficile
où il ya eu beaucoup d'arrestations et a
eu vraiment de la mûre qui profèrent la
détention provisoire je pense qu'il ya
eu des engagements de la part du
président de la république pour que la
procédure judiciaire permette la relaxe
ou du moins l'acquittement de tous les
détenus d'opinion
ça commence à se faire il ya eu la
libération de monsieur albert on salue
parce que c'était important pour les
algériens qui est ces mesures
d'apaisement qu'ils voient que ye qui
lie à des gestes forts en ce qu'ils vont
faire les détenus c'est important on
salue mais il faut aller jusqu'au bout
il faut libérer tous les détenus
d'opinion
il faut il ne suffit plus de relâcher
qu'il faut relaxé car aujourd'hui le
venin algériens veulent vraiment avoir
le droit de le droit de dire ce qu'ils
veulent le droit de défendre leur avait
le droit de défendre leurs opinions et
la place des journalistes la plate des
minutes on n'est pas en prison mais on
liberté pour défendre les intérêts du
pays alors sa mire d'un art by qui a été
acquitté hier après plusieurs mois donc
passé en détention il y aussi mustapha
benbada qui le rédacteur en chef d'un
quotidien annaba est ce que cela montre
une justice qui va dans le bon sens
celui de la transparence et de l'équité
sincèrement je peux pas vous dire que la
justice va dans le bon sens parce que
tout le monde fait en algérie que la
justice n'est pas libre aujourd'hui il
ya des des engagements politiques la
date du pouvoir algérien qui dit que
cette prose et procédure judiciaire
permettra la libération des détenus
d'opinion
on sait tous que c'est un choix
politique et est pour ça que j'en parle
politiquement il faut que le pouvoir
libère tous les détenus d'opinion
même si ça se fait via la procédure
judiciaire mais il faut vraiment la
libérer tous les détenus d'opinion
il ya encore des journalistes ya
quelques militants en prison que ces
gens là soient libérés et jugé en
liberté sinon il faut vraiment éclaircir
la situation il faut communiquer sur le
pourquoi de cette détention préventive
mais de là à utiliser comme ça
détention préventive de manière à caser
automatique ne pense pas que ce soit la
meilleure manière de prouver aux
algériens qui lie à accueillir volonté
politique de construire un état de droit
ce qui est la revendication première du
mouvement populaire le 22 février
alors on est à la veille du procès de
deux journalistes tels crimes
ighil est on en parlait et line dance
est ce que vous êtes inquiet non
sincèrement je me suis pareil qui est
pour monsieur dream chez madame nacelle
pourquoi parce que déjà ils sont jugés
en étant libre ils seront libres demain
et franchement avec tout avec ce qu'on
leur reproche incitation à tout va mais
je pense que tous les agrès sol algérien
serait jugé pour pour la même raison
d'être qui a eu quelques millions
d'algériens qui sont sortis dans la rue
depuis le 22 février
donc là vraiment un dossier ne pense
qu'ils sont relax et j'espère qu'ils
vont être relaxé et que tous les détenus
d'opinion soient relâchés qu'on puisse
passer à une autre étape de notre
militantisme politique d'aller vers un
dialogue sérieux avec le pouvoir
retrouver sortie de crise qui traduisent
effectivement les revendications du real
et qui permettent à l'algérie de revenir
à la légitimité populaire
alors depuis l'élection de 2008 et boone
s dans quelles conditions aujourd'hui
vous évoluez évolué l'opposition et
évoluent les manifestants le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya un problème
de confiance avec les les vingt
dernières années du régime vote final
les gens ne font pas confiance même s'il
ya des engagements de la part du
président on et ce n'est pas suffisant
aujourd'hui pour aller vraiment vers
l'intérieur pour aller vraiment
discussions avec avec le pouvoir actuel
mais et c'est pour ça que la question
des détenus restent très importantes si
les études d'opinion sont libérés qui la
condition première de toute la classe
politique de toute l'opposition
politique pour aller vers un dialogue
je pense que ça ça permettra d'apaiser
la situation est de passer à une autre
étape
il ya eu plusieurs rencontres de
monsieur hezbollah avec quelques
personnalités dont le président de
djidja dit monsieur sofiane jinan et
c'est important c'est très bien et a eu
des engagements mais comment l'un des
enjeux sera on jugera sur pièces il faut
aller plus loin il faut ouvrir les
médias
il faut libérer les détenus il
pour ouvrir la freine politique et
permettre aux algériens de parler
d'exprimer leur avis pour qu'on puisse
aller à un dialogue qui nous permettra
de changer la constitution de changer
quelques lois et d'aller vers de vraies
élections et permettant de revenir à la
légitimité populaire que la société
algérienne soit vraiment représenté
politiquement au sein d'un parlement
merci beaucoup à biba brahmia je
rappelle que vous êtes un secrétaire
exécutive chargée de la communication du
parti ed jil jadid merci à eux